albert einstein nos decía que nuestra
mente es como un paracaídas solo
funciona cuando ésta sea los invito a
todos ustedes a abrir sus mentes de
hablar de agua porque si nosotros
hablamos de agua estábamos hablando de
ella muy buenas tardes mi nombre es
vicente pero igual que casi la mayoría
de todos ustedes estoy compuesto en un
70% de agua
adivinen qué contiene mi sangre mis
pulmones y mi cerebro vamos a ir a agua
el ser humano y el entorno que lo rodea
somos pura agua esto si yo les pregunto
qué pasaría si nosotros no tuviéramos
este vital elemento quizás se nos ha
visto de una u otra forma pero solo
vamos a entender cuando nos esté
ocurriendo esperemos no quejarnos cuando
sea demasiado tarde
a los 11 años
una tarde de verano jugando con mis
primos en la piscina llenando globos con
agua malgastando el agua llegó estada el
abuelo que se nos fue a los 100 años
esta tarde el abuelo nos regaño hombre
de campo no puede repetir sus palabras
en público nos dijo que el pozo se nos
iba a llegar y como más sabe el diablo
por viejo que por diablo ocurrió así se
nos secó el pozo el hecho de no tener
agua para poder tomar lavar la ropa
lavar la loza nos hizo cambiar el valor
en relación a este vital elemento porque
seamos claros nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a valorar las cosas cuando
cuando las cosas las perdemos
sin embargo al entrar a clases luego de
terminado el verano
y al colegio me bastó el primer recreo
para poder ver que mis compañeros
malgastada en el agua el director los
profesores y los auxiliares no hacían
nada claro como ellos no pagan la cuenta
entonces con un entusiasmo inexplicable
llegué a mi casa tomé un trozo de
cartulina un par de plumones e hice mi
primera pista en relación a el cuidado
del planeta
este decía
cuidemos el agua
la expectativa era mira el vicente hice
una ficha acerca del cuidado del agua
teníamos que cuidar el agua sin embargo
la realidad fue otra
ustedes ya dieron cuenta de escribir
agua
especial will fue conocido como el niño
que describe agua con hache pero esta
ficha
junto con la constancia permitió que un
niño de 13 años de una escuela rural de
una localidad del sur de chile se
sentará a conversar con un niño de norte
américa europa asia oceanía áfrica en la
conferencia internacional
infanto-juvenil cuidemos el planeta en
brasil los llevar con mi paso entre la
enseñanza básica y la enseñanza media
en la enseñanza media yo estaba súper
contento porque nadie conocía no
la tarea del agua con h pero acaba más
bien me molestaban como el niño zafrada
que cuida la tierra
cuatro años estuve en el grupo ecológico
amanecer del liceo del centenar y los
ángeles promoviendo campañas de
reciclaje y sobre todo campañas del
cuidado del agua
ahora yo quería compartir con todos
ustedes técnicas que nos permiten
ahorrar cantidades significativas de
agua técnicas para todos sin importar
nuestra raza nuestra distinción ni
siquiera el dinero son cosas que tenemos
en nuestra casa y que generan un gran
impacto en el ahorro de este vital
elemento primero
el solo hecho de utilizar un vaso luego
enjuagar nuestros dientes nos permite
ahorrar hasta 10 mil litros de agua en
el plazo de un año calendario si amigos
con los 10 mil litros de agua que usted
pierde al poder enjuagar sus dientes
dejando la llave corriendo en el baño
podríamos satisfacer las necesidades de
400 niños en ciudad del cabo
tienes desde el día cero en adelante se
ha convertido en la primera ciudad en el
mundo en quedarse seca donde la cantidad
de litros por agua y por persona por día
perdón es de hasta 25 litros de agua 5
veces menos que lo que nosotros
consumimos en un mismo día
otra técnica que es muy importante es el
hecho de utilizar el jabón lo conocemos
si estamos y nosotros lo ponemos en el
lavamanos para poder acumular el agua y
así la habana nuestra cara nos permite
ahorrar cantidades impactantes de agua y
hay una que es la favorita de muchos yo
les recomiendo todos ustedes que en vez
de ducharse bañe más
acortamos los tiempos de ducha porque si
nosotros acortamos las duchas claramente
vamos a ahorrar cantidades importantes
de agua lo que yo hago colocó una
canción de fondo
en la miel se le escurrió papas y
empieza el escudo papá termina el escudo
papá terminó mi ducha hay una que les va
a gustar y yo creo que es hoy día en
adelante la van a empezar a practicar
más seguido
tomen duchas dados si mañana con su
polola con pololo con quien sea pero si
tomamos los tratados y ambos
contribuimos a crear un gran impacto en
el ahorro del agua y hacer un uso
eficiente de este vital recurso
ahora vivió el tiempo
quería recordar ese niño de 11 años a
ese niño que sin querer escribió agua
con hache pero que llamó la atención de
sus compañeros hoy ese mismo niño ya
tiene 21
y no solo busca llamar la atención de
sus compañeros sino que también llamar
la atención del mundo
agua que no has de beber no la dejes
correr a todos ustedes muchas gracias
por su atención
[Aplausos]